[Applaudissements]
ce que ça vous paraît long de parler
quinze minutes devant 600 personnes pour
essayer d'exprimer une idée sur le temps
je vais peut-être faire oui jouer tête
fernand y en a qui réagissent pas du
tout en réalité cette question est
beaucoup trop personnel et n'a pas d'
unique réponse puisqu'elle ne dépend que
de notre propre perception de la durée
en revanche ce qui nous connecte tous
ensemble dans cette question fait que
l'on comprend de quelle durée je parle
c'est bien le mot minutes tout comme les
secondes et les heures elles sont notre
quantification du temps elle nous aide à
vivre ensemble plus ou moins
correctement sans garantir d'arriver à
l'heure et je dis ça en connaissance de
cause j'ai 22 ans je suis artiste et ma
pratique artistique s'est orienté vers
ces différentes perceptions que l'on
peut avoir du temps et de la durée alors
cela peut paraître anecdotique mais j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser autant le jour
où j'ai arrêté de porter une montre au
poignet c'est anecdotique dans le sens
où j'ai simplement arrêter de la porte
et le jour voilà simplement cessé de
fonctionner après ça j'ai décidé de ne
plus jamais emporté ce choix qui n'est
pas le fruit d'une meilleure réflexion
reste néanmoins l'une des décisions la
plus importante que j'ai prise puisque
elle m'a aidée à sortir partiellement du
conditionnement de la perception
standardisée du temps
j'entends par là qu'avec le et le
réflexe de regarder ma montre
constamment j'avais l'impression de
vivre avec un métronome
d'ailleurs combien de personnes ce soir
ne porte pas de montre
on est ensemble voilà résultat des
courses ce choix n'était en aucun cas
une finalité
on ne porte pas toutes et tous des
montres au jour le jour
cependant je suis sûr que ceux qui n'en
portent pas sont comme moi et comme
n'importe quelle personne de ma
génération avec un smartphone au 1 % qui
indique l'heure quand la batterie n'est
pas à plat et comme tout impératif comme
ce soir par exemple on se doit d'être
ponctuel alors où est ce que je veux en
venir avec cette histoire de montres de
smartphones prenons un exemple très
simple je vous ennuie à mourir vous
passez un très mauvais moment avec moi à
m'écouter parler du temps vous compter
les minutes qui nous sépare entremont
début de temps de parole et ma faim de
temps de parole vous commencez à
regarder votre montre votre smartphone a
été secrètement encore 10 minutes
alors là le temps commence à s'élargir
tout devient interminable pendant que la
personne d'à côté de vous et subjugué
par la couleur de mes chaussettes et se
demande si ce n'est pas une faute de
goût une énorme faute de goût ou que
peut-être je n'avais pas de chaussettes
noires dans mon dressing aujourd'hui en
fait ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que le temps était lastic avant de
produire mes premières oeuvres je suis
passé par une phase d'expérimentation où
je mettais en jeu deux choses ma
conscience et ma présence je vais
commencer par la conscience l'idée de
cette expérimentation était de regarder
l'herbe pousser parce que l'herbe c'est
typiquement genre de choses où l'on
comprend qu'elles poussent seulement
quand elle a poussé au moment de la tour
l'idée est temps pour moi de d'observer
une croissance difficilement visibles
le par l'oeil humain très simple je suis
arrivé dans ce parc
je me suis assis avec ma loupe
mg on réglait et pendant dix heures
j'ai regardé un brin d'herbe pousser
sans le lâcher du regard en prenant
quelques mesures régulièrement
petit à petit j'ai vu ce brin d'herbe
passer les quelques millimètres l'idée
n'était pas pour moi de me dire qu'en
effet l'herbe pousse mais plutôt de
comprendre à quel rythme et le pousse à
quel rythme je dois m'habituer mois
humains pour voir cette chose poussé à
quel moment je dois oublier ma propre
temporalité pour me focaliser sur
l'évolution de quelque chose d'autre à
quel moment je dois prendre conscience
que les choses autour de moi évolué
est-ce que vous avez déjà regardé des
cheveux poussent et non et bien pour en
avoir fait l'expérience
c'est difficile de passer inaperçu avec
sa petite loupe et son règle est un mais
c'est presque encore plus beau que de
regarder l'herbe qui pousse deuxième
expérimentation ma présence l'idée cette
fois était pour moi de passer 24 heures
dans un endroit complètement hermétique
autant c'est à dire sans montre son
smartphone dans un endroit complètement
hermétique à la lumière dans l'idée de
vivre le temps sans repères temporels
exact je suis allée de manière très
précaire avec mon type led mes petites
brioches dans un sac de quoi beau c'est
un petit peu dans un conteneur
industriel fermer ensuite depuis
l'extérieur
alors au début je me suis habitué à mon
espace j'ai commencé à travailler à
produire à essayer de manger et
j'insiste sur essayez de manger dans le
noir le plus complet pendant 24 heures
accrochée au plafond un appareil photo
programmé pour me prendre toutes les
deux heures avec un flash
moi je vous vois venir moi aussi je
pensais que ça allait devenir mon repère
temporel mais croyez moi après deux
heures passées dans l'obscurité un quand
la rétine s'est bien habitué
le flash marque le temps d'une telle
manière qu'ils des routes complètement
l'esprit
heure après heure flash après flash je
ne savaient plus quelle heure il était
et je n'avais plus aucune notion du
temps et là le sensible gagne sur le
rationnel mes repères temporels devenait
des choses beaucoup plus un film comme
la température par exemple je devinais à
quel moment le soleil était au dessus du
conteneur par la chaleur qui se faisait
sentir à l'intérieur une chaleur qui
variait quand même de plus d'une
vingtaine de degrés bon celle ci est
difficile de la refaire chez vous
cependant si ça vous amuse vraiment un
rien ne vous empêche de louer demain un
box de stockage vous de vous enfermer
dans votre dressing à votre aise
en fait ces expérimentations n'ont fait
que de me pousser un peu plus loin à
jouer encore plus avec ces temporalités
petit à petit j'ai commencé à produire
des oeuvres qui jouait réellement avec
la patience du spectateur comme par
exemple j'ai créé cette installation
sonore qui diffuse le son d'un tgv qui
passent à sa vitesse de pointe aux
décibels exact donc très fort un son qui
dure environ trois secondes diffusé que
dans l'espace d'exposition que toutes
les heures ou alors je me suis intéressé
à cette goutte d'eau produite par une
plante tropicale plante qui produit
cette goutte seulement quand elle se
sent en bonne santé
une goutte vous doutez bien qui varient
qui peut passer de 5 minutes à 24 heures
de production pour une seule et même
gouttes je me suis aussi intéressé
voilà vous avez vous allez vraiment vous
dire que c'est un artiste bergère je me
suis posé la question de combien de
temps ça peut mettre un rouleau de
scotch 9 à se dérouler depuis le plafond
résultat des courses j'ai fait cette
installation avec ce fameux rouleaux de
scotch et ça prend un jour pour 1 m vous
imaginez bien que c'est très lent quand
on arrive dans l'espace d'exposition
voit pas grand chose en fait j'ai
commencé à créer des oeuvres et à
questionner le spectateur sur sa propre
échelle du temps sur des évolutions qui
existe autour de nous qui ne nous
appartiennent pas mais qui nous échappe
mais qui restent importantes à savoir
parce que ces choses autour de nous et
évolué pendant que nous avec nos
évolutions nos technologies la médecine
nous avons l'impression gagner plus en
plus de temps donc qu'est ce que nous
faisons quand on gagne plus
ben quand nous gagnons plus en plus de
temps nous faisons beaucoup plus de
choses donc nous avons l'impression de
ne plus avoir de temps c'est paradoxal
n'est ce pas et c'est triste c'est
triste d'entendre des gens dire qu'ils
perdent ou gagnent du temps le temps on
ne perd pas on ne le gagne pas le temps
existe indépendamment notre personnes se
sont simplement nos obligations ne
devoir notre santé nos hobbies qui nous
pousse à penser que nous avons plus de
temps à consacrer à d'autres choses mais
le temps passe et continue à passer mais
on ne perd pas où on ne gagne pas de
temps j'ai d'ailleurs essayé récemment
de gagner du temps en vivant trois fois
la même heure dans la même journée le 27
octobre 2010
aff je réalise l'oeuvre living three
times tout à m ce qui signifie vivre
trois fois deux heures du matin je suis
parti à la frontière entre deux fuseaux
horaires ici entre l'espagne et le
portugal
le jour du passage à l'heure d'hiver
je me retrouve au portugal en espagne
pardon premièrement en espagne il est 1h
58 passes à sa 2 heures du matin qu'est
ce que je fais la frontière portugaise
est à 100 m portugal sur ce fuseau
horaire on retire une heure une heure du
matin qui est des brouettes
j'attends pour la deuxième fois le 27
octobre 2019 de revivre deux heures du
matin deux heures du matin est chouette
passage à l'heure d'hiver une heure du
matin
j'attends patiemment de vivre pour la
troisième fois dans ma vie
le 27 octobre 2010 9,2 heures du matin
un résultat des courses j'ai
théoriquement gagner du temps on est
d'accord mais cela veut-il dire que le
temps n'a pas cessé de fonctionner que
je n'ai pas continuer à vieillir comme
avant je n'ai pas continué à évoluer que
ma batterie ne s'est pas des charges et
non plus et bien pour avoir expérimenté
pour vous ce soir
un voyage dans le temps je peux
simplement vous affirmer que le temps
continue à passer
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que du
coup comment os comment on va jouer avec
l'élasticité du temps du coup puisque ça
au final on s'en fout on continue à
évoluer
vous avez déjà tous regardé un coucher
de soleil
ran plus basique c'est magnifique et
pourtant ça ne nous indiquent pas
l'heure exacte mais c'est quand même
beaucoup plus agréable à regarder qu'à
cadran n'est ce pas je vois des têtes ce
front ces deux personnes qui ont
sûrement des super belle montre là pas
trop d'accord avec ce petit mec de 22
ans là qu'est en train de nous expliquer
l'élasticité du temps moi ce que j'aime
avec le soleil par exemple c'est que
c'est ni trop lente ni trop rapide
seydoux et pourtant ça reste à 100% dans
notre temporalité je veux dire on se
base sur les astres depuis plus de 5000
ans maintenant et on se base sur les
astres depuis plus de 5000 ans et
pourtant ça reste à 100% dans notre
temporalité comme je disais donc ne
serait-il pas un bon point de départ
vers une vision moins radicale du temps
une vision moins saccadée une vision qui
ne se comptent pas en chiffres
tout simplement ouvrez les yeux observer
les choses simples du quotidien jouer de
votre conscience de votre présence en
fait de votre localisation et le temps
vous semblera peut-être un peu moins
régulier ou fait comme ces personnes qui
ce soir on réellement expérimenté
l'élasticité du temps en s'ennuyant
pendant que je parlais merci
[Applaudissements]